so the release date or the cosmos yeah
the release date is crappy April 2 2013
if we are lucky and we have enough time
to organize it we plan to do it on the
12th of April which is the anniversary
of Gagarin's flight so there is plenty
of parties around the world to celebrate
first man in space so we are going to
try to not fit in that date and if now
it's going to be a little bit later but
always nipride we want to premiere the
filming in a festival like South by
Southwest or maybe Tribeca so we are in
conversations with them to try to come
and film there and then make the
worldwide premiere online in our website
and at the same time
no same day they and a DVD television
movie theaters and the Internet and on
the internet scramble for free for
everyone to watch
is there anyone helping you to get the
worldwide release out or to enter into
festivals or is it pretty much the
series intact
it was pretty much ourselves till this
trip we made to LA where we met with
somebody that we knew long time ago
which is John rice is one of the best
doing these things and I think is
getting on board to help us with the
situation in some ways Andres Sanders
comes along with with all the US
distribution which are we are really
happy about that
I know for John Riis and sherry Kamla
they always talk about making your film
screening an event so aside from a
premiering and a festival when you do
screen do you plan to do anything that
turns it into an event absolutely
absolutely we I mean besides the
traditional distribution that can't
happen at the same time we plan to do I
mean trying to turn every movie theater
screening into an event it's like
different things we we build what we
call the Partnership Program which will
allow everyone in every part of the
world to organize the premiere of the
cosmonaut so you can have like a pack
with merchandise on the film and many
ideas to make it very special and
everyone's going to be able to organize
a premiere it doesn't matter if it's
just for your five friends in your
living room or if you have a movie
theater of a thousand seats you know
it's so you can just spend as much money
as you want and then we're gonna split
the benefits of that and we have plenty
of people are and you have people in
like 14 countries that are willing to
organize the play of the cosmonaut and I
think that number is going to grow and
at the same time we're gonna have it an
on-demand tool and website so you're
gonna be able to see who is willing
towards a film in a certain city and
you're gonna have their email so you're
gonna have you know you're going to be
able to organize something more or less
having an idea of how many people's can
attend and at the same time because all
the transmedia nature of the project
we're gonna try to make these screenings
into something very special with some
transmedia elements and even you know
turning them into something more than a
film maybe even with factors and you
know we're gonna build a narrative
experience similar to how like the age
of stupid
for example they did a great great great
premiere you know getting people in line
I'm screaming you know yeah something
like that
you